diego our rights in specifically for TV
how does one balance giving a satisfying
season or episode for that matter plot
and closure with complete character arcs
while leaving room for a new season that
might be made well you don't want to
heal the wounds that that's basically it
you take a show like Animal Planet
Animal Kingdom I can't remember now
Kingdom Animal Kingdom which is a great
show about John Wells who's kind of
specializing now and taking foreign
shows and then turning him into American
shows you've got a matriarch a poisonous
matriarch Ellen Barkin and her and her
kids who she's completely massively
screwing up constantly you know you just
never want to have those kids get better
and they don't what I've just been
killed and the others are just as
poisonous as they were there just a nest
of snakes I mean the great thing about
television is is that you you you you
replace healing which is what you get in
a movie with surprise
okay so characters don't change in
television they surprise with new often
appalling aspects of the character you
didn't know about for instance let me
ask you this you probably have a someone
you've known for twenty years right few
people and you get you know them better
and better right some of them and you
get to know them better and better
don't you find they're insanely
appalling people oh my god they're even
worse than I thought
yes so that's television and it's like
you know it's not like that those people
are gonna heal and you go see you later
Dave I'm glad you're you don't know with
your mother anymore everything is great
it's like oh my god
Dave's really apparent where you're
learning new things about them
right now yeah he wasn't the person I
think no I know yeah you're learning a
new things about them that shock you
they're surprising okay
for instance in time The Sopranos what
she talked about earlier
Janice is getting married to a guy named
Richie
a prio and they're they're discussing
their wedding plans one night and he
gets angry at her and suddenly he slaps
her what you've never ever seen him do
before he's never been violent to her
that's a surprise that Richie suddenly
slaps Janice it's not a change in his
character he's not getting worse he's
not doing we're doing a movie I'm
getting worse because my warns but he's
just being Richie but he's a surprise
then Janice goes to a closet while he's
selling you're eating his dinner put my
dinner on the table
and she comes out of the closet and
she's got a gun and he goes come nobody
shoot she shoots it right at the table
okay
that's a new surprise from you haven't
seen her do that before right so and is
she healing or did are getting worse no
she's just Janice it's a new revelation
of character right so the way you do it
in television is you keep surprising us
with new aspects of a character someone
reveals something about themselves you
didn't know before
that's what television is so great it's
more like real life than movies right
it's just you and your friends learning
more and more horrible appalling things
about each other that's you as you go
along and they're not things that are
gonna make you go well they're healing
or they give it up it's like a no that's
just here just horrible yeah and so
that's the big difference between movies
in television touch surprise replaces
healing
you